we're really excited about the
group of candidates that we're going to
be interviewing over the next
several days and i think
maybe despite all the changes we've made
i think it's a very attractive job
everybody in the nfl knows how important
football is in this area
i think everybody understands we have a
really good young quarterback and a
really good core group of players so
we're excited about the opportunity to
work with these candidates over the next
week or two or how long it takes
jimmy haslam owner of the cleveland
browns meeting with the media yesterday
making it clear they want someone with
nfl experience that statement from him
came on the same day there was a report
from fox that urban meyer of fox is
someone in whom the browns have strong
interest apparently that's not the case
they want somebody with that nfl
experience and big cat i think what
they're looking for
is a strong head coach who will then
decide who to hire to help set the table
they need to have everybody on the same
page that's where they've gotten it so
wrong they have internal factions that
don't see eye to eye they butt heads
and now
you've got more dysfunction with the
browns dysfunctional teams do
dysfunctional things and they need to
find a path out of the dysfunction and
that is
one organization everyone on the same
page no complicated depth chart of
who's reporting to whom and who's here
and who's over there and who's part-time
working in california like uh uh
d podesta does get one guy in charge of
the organization and trust that guy to
turn it around and i don't know if
they'll do that that's why the when when
jimmy haslam says it's an attractive job
how can you look at what the browns have
done in the last decade in the last 20
years and say that's an attractive job
they change coaches they change front
offices every other year it feels like
so i it's crazy i don't know of course
someone's gonna take the job because
what happens is there are borderline
guys who say unless they can get an old
school guy you know maybe mike mccarthy
does take the shot but if they don't get
a guy who's been in the nfl for a long
time who's been a head coach they'll get
someone who says you know what this
might be my only chance as a head
coaching job so i'm not maybe i'm not
ready but i'm gonna go take it mike let
me throw out one name to you you don't
want that though you don't want that guy
you want a guy who has choices you don't
want freddy kitchens who's gonna take it
though mike besides mike mccarthy and
like who who else who else is out there
i i'll tell you who's out there and who
if the browns were smart they would
literally just make
lincoln riley the best paid coach in the
nfl back up what about what about giving
what about giving the keys to josh
mcdaniels and saying we'll get rid of
pauldy podesta uh but we're only where
you're in charge josh you decide who's
going to be your gm vp of player
personnel but you run the show you love
baker mayfield get the most out of baker
mayfield here's a six year fully
guaranteed contract with no offset
language so you don't have to worry
about getting thrown out the door
prematurely like we've done over and
over and over again why not give it to
mcdaniels
because do you think mcdaniels has has
learned i mean last year i know people
are going to say it doesn't matter as
much but last year the colts thing with
mcdaniels was bizarre and going back and
forth
that was the chance for mcdaniels to say
has he learned from denver when he
basically you know alienated the entire
locker room he came in
did the tebow thing trading jay cutler
all this stuff
that's what mcdaniels did in denver that
alienated the entire locker room and
basically set that team back right so
has he learned from that i don't know
because the colts thing was bizarre so
if you have josh mcdaniels he you have
to be 100 sure he's the guy because josh
mcdaniels is not the type of guy who you
can bring in and then hire someone above
him to tell him what to do you you are
then doing it he's got a baby you're
doing exactly what you're saying where
it's josh mcdaniels runs the whole
organization top to bottom he gets
everything
do you really think that that's what you
want to do though mike
i i all i want is everyone to be on the
same page that's what i want cleveland
is not going to turn this thing around
until they have someone that they trust
to whom they give the keys and also
jimmy haslam and dee haslam need to get
out of the way they can't do they're
constantly taking opinions from other
people and listening to this person
listening
just just be a fan right count the money
and be a fan and get out of football
operations that is advice that i would
give to any owner in the nfl look at
what do you think bob kraft is heavily
involved in football operations i mean
you let him know what's going on for big
decisions but other than that that's why
bill bella checks there that's why you
hire experts you keep out of it and you
just enjoy the games yeah and if you
want to go with the bill belichick
analogy here josh mcdaniels if you have
him if you bring him in and you make him
the full guy and bill belichick has a
famous saying where it's like you know
if we're all pulling together we could
be wrong but we still be right because
everyone's on the same page and
everyone's going after the same thing
and josh entails as long as you think he
can run the whole thing and giving him
the keys go for it you're right go for
it
well he's learned at the elbow of bill
belichick twice now before he took the
broncos job and then for the last decade
again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports